America brace yourselves for Baywatch
Biden influencers can't get enough of
Joe at the beach if indeed they're real
one tweeting quote backwards hats
aviators and relaxation Joe Biden is
pretty cool okay Harry how much they pay
you for that one no word yet if he's
going to be running in slow-mo though
but Biden is on vacation all week
cruising around on his bike and hoping
not to fall off while the presidential
pinup is building sand castles though
another Democrat is becoming a 2024
hassle Congressman Dean Phillips is
considering a run for the White House
after opposing a Biden re-election does
this make the Biden team nervous
it doesn't have me nervous frankly
um President Biden has the strongest
record of legislative accomplishment
since LBJ and you're beginning to see
the impact 13 million jobs created by
the private sector 800 000 good
manufacturing jobs 35
000 infrastructure projects out there in
the country team Phillips can't cite
anything like that the base of the
democratic party as broadly as I've ever
seen in my life is endorsing President
Biden because of what he's gotten done
Kitty can I positive the theory to you
Joe spends roughly 40 percent of his
presidency on vacation is that a bad
thing given that when he's not on
vacation we go to pot I mean maybe the
longer we expect to do yeah
sorry I didn't mean to call you out on a
Monday
um I actually think a strategy is a good
one I mean Republicans are trying to
figure out what they're doing they have
a primary debate DNC is protecting Joe
Biden from a primary debate there's no
reason for him to get out in the press
and say things that can be used against
him at this point and so it makes sense
that he would be staying on the beach
for a couple of weeks so Republicans
spend money and try to figure out how
they can possibly beat Donald Trump even
though they're 40 points behind however
eventually it seems like he's going to
have to get out and do some campaigning
you know Democrats have a problem with
taking advantage of certain voting
blocks and thinking that they're not
going to have to work for for votes and
I think that there's certain groups that
are looking at his economic agenda so
when it comes to inflation they're
saying actually it hasn't been so good
for me and the White House has really
been trying to sell it without Joe Biden
out there doing it on his own so but
overall it's probably good for him to be
at the beach for a while Republicans are
on the campaign Trail and he doesn't
have to be till next year you know
Jessica Democrats are saying that
President Biden has the best record on
legislation since LBJ what does LBJ
stand for
not doing it it stands for what the BJ
anyway
he does look great he does look great I
know that Jesse wants to talk about his
physique and crazy
for 80 years old he does look great and
also the way that Joe Biden and Jill
Biden go to the beach is like normal
people right they're not by the pool at
some fancy Resort like they're in their
beach chairs with a cooler and yeah
they're a secret service around but
they're on a public beach are there six
million dollar beach house
paid for please
if you look at that that looks like two
normal people going to the beach I
understand that they have a fancy house
So what at this point and these gen Z
influencers
now there was a ton of Articles kind of
before the 22 midterms and then 2022 and
then it happened again talking about how
he's losing the youth vote the youth
vote is back and they're all in on him
now because of issues like climate
change
because and because he took off his
shirt and he shimmied which we don't
have the footage of
um and the Republicans like to make fun
of this strategy of people getting out
there with huge social media followings
they would give anything to have a kid
with hundreds of thousands of followers
say something positive about a
republican politician but there's
nothing going on in the Republican party
that aligns with what younger they call
me Nazi some kid comes out as a
conservative gets trashed online by the
likes of you Jessica
flag maybe but if not I would never call
him a Nazi you know Jesse uh some of the
media are marveling at shirtless Joe I
think it's a relief that he took the
shirt off at a beach and not at a
restaurant where he thought it might
have been the beach yes okay
that's a very low bar
and this proves that a republican hack
he looked great
you look great how old is he he's 80
years old he looked trim he looked good
it was staged but I hope I look like
that when I'm 80 years old you said he
looks like every day Americans I don't
want that he looks like my dad I don't
want him to just sit on the beach with a
book or last time he was at the beach he
just passed out in the sun show me a
little Vigor go body surfing like Obama
I mean Trump just hit a nine iron about
six feet from the pin on the night's all
over the weekend I do not want to see
Trump with his shirt off okay I don't
want to see anybody with his shirt off
except RFK Jr and Greg ah thank you okay
but obviously this was staged because he
looked ridiculous glistening with lotion
all over all hanging loose in a lounge
chair that he couldn't carry two weeks
ago but do a little more than that
um this guy Dean who's running never
heard of him so goodbye no one's afraid
of Dean not even Dean's wife
widespread cover-up going on with
Joe Biden okay he's dropping campaign
finance charges against many after they
bought the senate for him and and then
he's trying to arrest his political
opponent while he's trying to keep his
son out of prison and quarantine this
investigation from getting him impeached
This Guy's in deep trouble and the fact
that he's still tied with Donald Trump
at this point shows how deep of a
trouble he's in you know he rejected
sunblock Dana because he said he'd
already cured cancer that's true I mean
I have a question on you as somebody
that worked in the white house where to
the Secret Service when they're at the
beach can they dress like in Beachwear I
saw I saw one of them today he was in a
polo shirt and khakis so he just has to
stand there yeah below certain
characters because you kind of want to
blend in yeah you do you know but it's
hard to blend in with dark sunglasses if
somebody's drowning that isn't the
president do they have to act or do they
just let him drown they don't no your
first and foremost obligation is to the
president but I think that if the Secret
Service were there and somebody were
drowning that they would try to help yes
oh okay yes
um okay what I was gonna say is so I'm
often very comfortable with Congress
being in recess and presidents being
away that means that they're not issuing
executive orders that are going to make
things more expensive for you or like
Banning gas burning stoves or your
washing machine or anything like that
but the seat the thing about President
Biden being out there do you remember
when John Kerry was on the windsurf yes
and that video and so he was out there
windsurfing and it was uh August Late
July August and that became the campaign
and that said do you want this guy to be
your president this is what he's
spending his time doing it wasn't
relatable being at the beach okay that
might be a little bit relatable but the
CBS poll just put him at his lowest
approval rating of his presidency
including a horrible rating for his
handling of the economy and everybody
that was on the Sunday shows that was a
Democrat this weekend was trying to tell
people
you will
accept how great this economy is because
you will do it it was like you like
there had to there's not even trying to
persuade they're just telling people
that they're wrong and I think that
that's going to be a big problem the
last thing I would say is CNBC at a poll
that said 61 of Americans are living
paycheck to paycheck there you go and so
if you're sitting on the beach at a time
when you really want to win this
election if you really want to win I get
it taking a week off but you're gonna
have to show a little bigger on the
campaign Trail when you get back
the beach another thing that Democrats
have ruined
I probably won't go back again because
of this event hi winner Brian Kilmeade I
want you to do me a favor I want you to
click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the silly way that
I know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now